PRIME TIME PROGRAM, 10:00
EASTERN RIGHT ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL AND HIS RADIO
SHOW WILL BE SIMULCAST ON
FOX NATION.
TAKE A BOW SIR.
WELCOME TO THE FAMILY.
ALTHOUGH YOU'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF
THE FAMILY.
YOU'VE GOT A MAJOR PROMOTION IN
>> SEAN, LISTEN, IT'S REALLY
BEEN A LONG JOURNEY.
I'VE BEEN DOING APPEARANCES ON
FOX FOR TEN YEARS.
YOU WERE GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO HAVE
ME -- REMEMBER THE GREAT
AMERICAN PANEL?
2011.
>> Sean: YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
A WISE GUY ABOUT IT, ATTACK ME
BECAUSE I'M OLD.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
>> YOU HAD THE FOOTBALL, YOU HAD
TEDDY NANCE ON THE PANEL, I'LL
NEVER FORGET IT, IT WAS MY FIRST
APPEARANCE ON YOUR SHOW AND ON
FOX AT ALL IN PRIME TIME AND YOU
KNOW, YOU TOOK A CHANCE.
I KNOW YOU DON'T TAKE COMPLEMENT
SWELL, TOO BAD, YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO EAT THIS ONE.
YOU REALLY TOOK A CHANCE ON ME
EARLY.
I APPRECIATE IT, I WANT TO THANK
FOX AND THE MANAGEMENT ALSO WILL
SUFFER HAVING FAITH IN ME AND MY
CONTENT AND I WON'T DISAPPOINT
THE AUDIENCE, WE ARE GOING TO
BRING IT EVERY SATURDAY NIGHT AT
10:00, I AM BEYOND EXCITED.
IT'S BEEN A LONG JOURNEY.
>> Sean: IT HAS BEEN.
JUST COMMENT ON THE OVERALL
STATE OF THINGS BECAUSE MARK
WITHIN, I CAN SEE HIM IN THE
MONITOR, HE'S LITERALLY CHOMPING
AT THE BIT.
HE JOINS US NEXT, OUR MUTUAL
FRIEND.
I'M LOOKING AT ALL THAT'S GOING
ON WITH ISRAEL.
I'M LOOKING AT WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH CHINA, RUSSIA, AND IRAN.
I'M LOOKING AT THE BORDER.
I'M LOOKING AT, YOU KNOW, A
HACK, A CYBER ATTACK THAT SHUTS
DOWN OUR ENERGY SUPPLY.
I'M LOOKING AT ENERGY JOBS LOST,
STROKE OF A PEN AND A WAR ON
ENERGY JOBS AND I'M NERVOUS FOR
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW AND THIS
GUY IS ASLEEP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> SEAN, YOU KNOW, YOU SHOULD
BE.
WE ARE REALLY AT THE REDLINE
RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE AT 9,000 RPMs AND
EVERYONE NEEDS TO PAY ATTENTION.
EVERYTHING WE WARNED WHAT
HAPPENED -- IF BIDEN DID X WE
SAID WHY WOULD HAPPEN.
IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
WE WARNED THEM.
UNBELIEVABLE SPENDING LEVELS AND
GOVERNMENT BLOWOUTS WOULD LEAD
TO INFLATION.
4.2% HEADLINE INFLATION THIS
MONTH.
WE WARNED THEM, YOU KNOW,
DISRUPT THE GROWING ENERGY
INDUSTRY IN THIS COUNTRY, WHAT
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE?
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A GAS
CRISIS.
WHAT HAPPENS?
WE ARE HAVING A GAS CRISIS.
WE WARNED THEM DON'T OPEN OF THE
SCHOOLS, YOU'RE GOING TO GET A
BUNCH OF PARENTS REALLY UPSET
CAN FIND A WAY TO EDUCATE THEIR
KIDS.
WHAT HAPPENED?
IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
WE WARNED THEM INTERNATIONAL
WEAKNESS OVERSEAS WAS GOING TO
LEAD TO GLOBAL DISRUPTION.
WHAT HAPPENED?
YOU'RE SEEING IT NOW.
FOLKS IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
YOU'VE GOT TO WAKE UP, THIS IS
SERIOUS.
SADLY EVERYTHING IS POLITICAL.
THIS IS AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT,
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE UNITED STATES.
EDUCATED KIDS AND A COUNTRY NOT
CONSTANTLY BITING AT EACH OTHER
BECAUSE THE LEFT WANTS TO PAINT
EVERYONE OF THEIR OPPONENTS AS A
RACIST.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
FUTURE WE HAVE AND BELIEVE ME,
IT GIVES ME ABSOLUTELY N